you know what amazed me you're obviously
uh you're very young uh man especially
contrasted with myself and yet you're so
many musical influences are these people
that uh you know Eric Clapton it was a
huge influence on you and I think well
you're very young to be influenced by
Eric Clapton but of course he's Timeless
the way the Beatles are Timeless the way
I basically I just had my dad's record
collection it's very like cliched of
like that's what I listen to but it
wasn't until like you know Christmases
where maybe an aunt sends you £10 and
then you can go out and buy the CD that
you want to get but I was very much like
I only listen to my dad's record
collection cuz that's what we had in the
house so I guess I was like 10 or 11
when I started forming my own tastes but
but yeah there was I mean my dad has
some great records and they're still
like some of my like Moon Dan Van
Morrison I think is like a perfect album
for any time like anytime you put that
on it could be like the end of the night
it could be the start of the night it
could be like dinner like it's just just
it's a perfect album did you say your
dad is is he from Belfast no so my dad's
dad is from Belfast and my dad's
M Ben Morrison's from Northern Ireland
and so I just think you never know where
some things are coming to you or why
things appeal to you he doorstepped me
at my uh um Hotel like it was like I was
I in like 2014 I just made Thinking Out
Loud um and it had become a hit and uh I
I remember my grand had actually come to
the gig and we had a lot of whiskey
afterwards as you do and I'd gone to bed
at like 4:00 in the morning and I
remember getting this phone call at like
6 I was like really blur just like what
and the person at the front Des is just
like Van Morrison's here he wants to
have breakfast with you and I was like
no he's
not thought someone was taking the piss
so I hung up and then they rung back and
they're like no no no he's actually
downstairs he wants to have breakfast
with you and I was like cool showered
really quickly went down and yeah just
essentially had breakfast with him it
was really surreal cuz I was still drunk
I was still it like 7:00 in the morning
I was just like is
this but he's really sweet I've got to
sort of like meet him a couple of times
since then but it was like such a nice
thing he's like he's like one of my
heroes and I was people always say don't
meet your Heroes and it was such a like
not that thing it was just sitting down
he was really interested in Spotify on
talk about that you were explaining it
to him then you explained how VCRs
worked I it it was relatively new at
this point all I knew is that on my
first album I remember cuz no one really
put their records on Spotify to begin
with cuz they didn't really know what
the what is this yeah it work and I was
like I want my I want everyone to have
my music and I just remember never
selling a record in Sweden and I it was
always like record sold in Sweden was
zero and then I'd go there and I'd play
the biggest gigs of my European tour and
I'm like this is weird the like
correlation like have I sold no records
here but the most people want to come
and see the songs and it's because
Spotify was so accessible I see okay you
know it was and that and I think I think
that's what's good about music now and
it's I mean it's more difficult to break
through with new songs because there's
100,000 new songs released every day but
like the quality will inevitably go up
because you know like back when I was a
teenager and buying albums and I think
this is why piracy became a thing is I
think record labels took the piss they
had like one great song that they' put
on an album with a bunch of filler and
they'd sell it to you for $22 or what 22
and you'd buy it and be like I feel
ripped off here and you be like I wish I
could just download that one song that I
liked and I think that's why it all they
basically pushed it too far ripped off
people too much right I'm curious um you
mentioned don't meet your Heroes I was
shocked you came
uh oh my God Sona please oh God but
Ed
Ed he is funny he he is
funny the point is
Ed who are other people that uh that you
met that obviously I mean you have
achieved this incredible success this
insane success you get to meet whoever
you want now in the music world were
there people where you thought I I mean
you have you have you checked off every
box you must have checked off my R was
always I'm never going to seek out
someone to meet them I'm going to wait
until they want to meet me I remember I
remember doing SNL not even doing SNL
I'd made my album with Rick rubben and
Rick Rick was also making M&M's album at
the time and Rick was like I want to do
SNL with uh Eminem you want to come down
and I was like yeah I'd love to and then
when I when I was there Rick was like do
you want to meet him and I was like no I
like I I want I want to but I want him
to be like hey I like your stuff so I
just waited and four years later was
then the time that he was like oh I like
your stuff we should do a song and now
we're actually friends and I feel I feel
like that's like a I I completely
understand what you're talking about my
I don't want the picture and the I no
and my constant assumption is which I I
mean I don't know I think it's the maybe
the healthier way to approach it but my
constant assumption is oh they don't
want to meet me and I definitely don't
want to ever have that feeling of well
here's a nice little treat for them
hello and they're they're not that happy
to see me that's I would die but I think
that that's sometimes why it's don't
meet your Heroes because people are
premature with with it what the guy that
made me start songwriting was Damen rice
and he is like a bit recl reclusive and
like you know at my Peak I met his
sister and stuff and I was like do you
think he'd ever like want to hang or
anything and she's just like I don't
know I guess you'll see him at some
point and you know I I guess I met him
when I was 12 and then when I was I
played in Iceland in rovic and it just
so happened he was there and that's the
time we hung out and we spent a good 48
hours together we like went on a hike we
got on a hot pool we had and it was like
one of those things of like this is why
I waited this is like it's it was a
really nice interaction yeah you waited
till it was organic and it was a real a
real moment rather than people pushing
you towards people forced yeah but no
I'd say I've met
allart from I haven't met Dylan that's
the only one that I would love to meet
but again like if you meet Bob Dylan
prematurely like I've told this story
and I met him in the worst way uh but I
think it Bears repeating which is I was
with I was yeah naked in the sauna I was
with my friend um right after a good
swim in the North Sea
uh um um no I went I went I went to see
Dylan play and of course I'm with my
good friend jimy Vino who's amazing uh
guitar player in my band leader for a
long time and he of course the next
thing I knew we were backstage and I've
been doing the show for a bunch of years
at that point and and suddenly I find
myself in this room and I wasn't
prepared and there was just this sort of
people moved around and then I was just
kind of pushed forward and I'm stand at
Bob Dylan's Right Where You Are are and
I'm right where I am and he it's that
phase where he has the tiny little drawn
on mustache and like the gun Gunslinger
flat hat and he's looking at me and he's
got that little mustache and he went hey
I know you from the
TV and I thought okay well at least I'm
in now and I can start talking to Bob
Dylan and I swear to God this happened
just as I'm about to you know say oh you
know Bob I hear Conan Conan hey hey
how's it going and I look over and it's
Vice pres former vice president Al
Gore and he's like come here come here
you know let's talk about the
environment
and yeah Al Gore is cool and everything
that's fine but Bob Dillan and then Bob
I turned around and Bob Dillan was like
gotta go and ran and like ran
away and I was blocked by the Vice
President of the United
States and I never saw Bob Dyan again
and that just rings in my head I know
you from the
TV and then that and then that's it I
think that's it that's it that's all I'm
going to get I had it with I was at the
the the GQ Awards and Tarantino was
there and my manager's wife was like you
got to say hi and I was like no no
honestly I I don't want to meet him
unless unless he wants to me she's like
you have to you have to you have to I
like no no I really don't and then the
more and more we drunk later on in the
night she just goes up to him and she's
just like anybody wants to meet you and
I'm like oh no and same thing just like
hey man yeah great like your films
thanks I say about the people I mean
that you've I mean like yes you've you
you know elen John and Clapton but you
also Beyonce and Jay-Z you've hung out
with them you've had you've broken bread
with them yes you've had food with yeah
well I I kind of like I got to know them
through really weirdly actually it was
um I played do you know what Jules
Holland is it's like so I played Jules
Holland's hoen anny which is like the
New Year's Eve show show and you play a
cover and they said what cover do you
want to do and I said well I do Stevie
W's Master Blaster cuz I love I love the
tune and two months later was the
Grammys and the guy that was running the
Grammys uh music Ken erck was like we're
going to do the Stevie W the tribute
concert for Stevie he's going to be in
the audience it's going to be with his
band Greg filling gam is going to be in
it uh we got all these people playing do
you want to play and I was like yeah and
he's like what do you want to play and I
went well I'll play Master Blaster I
just I literally just played it and he
was like great and then like two days
later he rung up and
went Beyonce wants to do Master Blaster
and I was and I was like that's totally
fine I'll do I I'll do I was made to
love her and then and then he Rong back
and was like would you sing it with
Beyonce and I was like uh
yeah and then you have a different life
than I
do I remember getting to because I'm not
it was with it was with Beyonce and and
and Gary Clark Jr and Gary Clark junr is
one of the best like living living
guitarist and uh uh I just remember like
I'm not a very talented guitarist I can
play to guitar and and chords and I
remember Ken coming off and being like
I've got this idea jeweling guitars you
and Gary and I was like I can play like
a C cord like but anyway so we did that
and then we all met at that thing and
then I then did like other shows with
her and then it was like one of these
ones of like you don't ask you don't get
I'd made this song Perfect that was uh
starting to pick up steam and become a
hit and um someone said oh we should put
out like a duet version of this cuz done
like a a Italian version with and Andrea
belli and they were like who would you
want to do it and I was like well
realistically I don't really want to do
do a duet unless it's Beyonce and they
were like well why don't you ask her and
she said yes and it was like it was I
was so surprised I was kind of rung her
up on I was like do you want to do it
she's like yeah I'm in and so it was it
was one of those it's that simple I
could just ring her up no what AM my
misunderstanding son no it's just Ed not
me no no yeah Ed can you can not no do
you know what I've learned what I've
learned in this in this business said if
you don't
try no but the worst thing the worst
thing that someone can say is no so if
you prepare yourself for the no like I
always say to you know if I'm doing
something like I'm on this tour at the
moment and occasionally I'll be in
cities where like so like Eminem came on
in Detroit but what I said to him was
like you can cancel on the DAT like I'm
not going to feel weird if you suddenly
go I'm coming so it's very much like I'm
always prepared for the No and when it's
a yes it's it's happy days I have I mean
in comedy I have this thing where all
these people that I grew up with and and
actually I'm going to include other
people that are younger than me who are
just so talented and when I'm around
them I sometimes step outside my own
body and go like oh it's crazy that I'm
with these people I mean how and it and
it's I think it's good not to lose that
you know I mean what's mad as well is
you do that probably with people that do
that with you as well like even you know
like young comedians now that are like
top of their game that you will hang out
they're probably going holy with
kind in a BRI you're going I can't even
believe they're in you know like it's a
right it's a nice thing I think it's
good to never lose that I think it's
good to to keep that sort of sense of
I'm getting away with murder because we
we are we're getting to do what we grew
up wanting to
do